du siehst aus wie Olaf Scholz mit
der oh voll
geil hallo herzlich willkommen in
sallyys Welt und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen Folge zu Gast bei Sally
heute habe ich einen ganz besonderen
Gast eine gastin
Gästin und ich kenne sie schon richtig
lange sie ist auch Youtuberin der ersten
Stunde sozusagen eine Youtube Oma mit
mir allerdings ist sie deutlich jünger
als ich muss man leider auch dazu sagen
ich liebe sie sehr ich schätze sie sehr
eine Zeitlang war sie bisschen offline
was mich sehr traurig gestimmt hat aber
auch zu derzeit hatten wir immer viel
Kontakt und ich bin so glücklich dass
sie endlich da ist in meiner Küche und
wir heute zusammen kochen Spaß haben
Sport machen whatever herzlich
willkommen sopia te hello W vellung ja
wir haben uns tatsächlich seit 2016 das
darf man eigentlich gar nicht sagen
vorgenommen Videos zusammenzumachchen
aber man kennt das ja bsy bsy die ganze
Zeit hoch und runter und jetzt statt
2016 wur dann 2023 ja wir haben es
geschafft das ist eine gute le besser
aus denn je kann ich nur zurückgeben
haben wir ein Foto von damals ich schau
mal ob wir ein Foto von damals haben ob
ich das finde also muss echt sagen
Wahnsinn danke schön Wahnsinn einfach
wahnsinn ich liebe deine Entwicklung ich
liebe deinen Content und du bist ja
eigentlich auch muss man sagen so die
erste große
bekannteste Fitness ich will influenzer
sagen Fitness Bloggerin Fitness
Youtuberin die so mit damit
durchgestartet ist ja damals gab's den
Begriff influenzer noch gar nicht und es
war bisschen so friss oder stirb und ich
hatte keinen Plan was ich Abi machen
soll und ich hatte Bodybuilding entckt
deswegen war das so eigentlich bin ich
reingerutscht aber hat mir dann auch
eigentlich es macht mir immer Spaß
Gemach vor der Kamera zu sein aber du
kennst es ja irgendwann verliert man
sich so in diesem
ganzen Business sage ich jetzt mal und
dann hatte ich so meine hohen Höhen aber
ganz tiefen tiefen und das muss ich
irgendwie erstmal lernen und deswegen äh
gut bist ja auch richtig jung da
reingestartet mit 19 mein erstes Youtube
Video war November 2014 dann eben reines
Bodybuilding da war ich der Fitness
Erklärbär
quasi rund um das Thema Körperformen
Kraftsport und so weiter hab dann selber
gemerkt okay das Leben besteht aber
nicht nur aus Diätplänen und und
Trainingspläne und Sixpack allein macht
D einfach nicht glücklich der gehört
mehr dazu aber muss es irgendwie auf die
harte Tour lernen heute bin ich ja mit
dem holistischeren Ansatz irgendwie
zurück spreche eben offen über mentale
Gesundheit eben auch in meinem Fall über
Essstörung und Depressionen weil früher
oder später erreichen dann irgendwann
immer mal so persönliche Krisen aber
auch da gibt's ein Weg durch und aber
Ernährung und Training begleitet mich
jetzt einfach bis heute und hab da e
ganz guten Weg mittlerweile gefunden
richtig richtig schön und du bist
einfach eine powerfu ich stehe hier und
fühle mich so richtig unprofessionell
als also wenn ihr das hier sehen könntet
es ist wirklich krass Quatsch alles also
mein Kento das ist halt ein anderes
Level ne mein Content bis vor ein paar
Jahren bestand ja tatsächlich nur aus
Torten und irgendwann habe ich ja dann
auch angefangen zu teilen was mich so
jeden Tag beschäftigt nämlich auch
gesundes Essen natürlich denn
Überraschung ich esse nicht jeden Tag
Kuchen und Torten den ganzen Tag und
natürlich möchte auch die Community
wissen wie ernährst du dich wie machst
du es mit den Kindern wie schaffst du es
alles vorzubereiten und ich dachte mir
eigentlich meine wir haben uns heute
nicht abgesprochen was wir tun werden du
bist da jetzt auch so bisschen ähm hast
jetzt überraschen lassen aber ich sehe
schon es geht in so eine Richtung fast
schon prepping weil man sieht hier
verschiedene Komponenten mehr von allem
so ein bisschen und das auch von mir das
ist nicht die Portion die wir heute für
eine Person auch der Reis z.B aber wir
prEN heute essen wir haben hier
tiefgefrorenen Lachs wir haben
Hähnchenbrust wir haben Naturreis wir
haben alles an Gemüse was teilweise
gegart gekocht wird oder auch roh wir
lassen auch viel Rohkost das Team hat
wieder wie in diesem Format üblich
Spiele vorbereitet von denen ich nichts
weiß sie sagt nur zieh Dich sportlich an
ich habe was Sportliches drunter wir
lassen uns überraschen ich hab den
Leggings an also ich bin bereit ich hab
Leggings drüber Jeans ich WUs nicht kann
ich jetzt in der Leggings hier stellen
dachte ich ich jetzt doch mal egal
später sehr gut D sch mal die Zucchini
genau die Ken wir vielleicht weiß nicht
mach wie du möchtest Würfeln klein
schneiden die Ken wir einfach später in
Olivenöl bissel braten und würzen und
ich schneide den Lachs schon mal der ist
noch gefroren und den könnt ihr gefroren
schneiden weil dann weil ihr dann
richtig perfekte Würfel machen könnt
dann marinieren wir den und dann kommt
er in dampfgara richtig gut das wusste
ich vorher nicht ich hatte den erst
auftauen lassen und dann geschnitten
geht auch aber so hast du halt perfekte
würfelm und dann zerfällt da auch
einfach nichts die
Hauswirtschaftslehrerin in mir würde
jetzt auch sagen Sophia bitte mach die
Haare zu und ich weiß dass viele von
euch das Schreiben werden aber wir
kochen jetzt hier kein Essen für andere
wir kochen es für uns deswegen für mich
ist es völlig okay klar Haare zusammen
und kurze Nägel weil ich war auf der
mächalchule bevor ich zur Fachoberschule
dann gegangen bin wegen Abitur und da
hatte ich den hauswirtschaftszweig aber
auch nur weil ich dachte so
Französisch keine Ahnung auf gar keinen
Fall fr
nö nee ich ich habe hauswirschaft
genommen we alle gedacht haben da kann
man einfach nur chillen und fressen aber
letend war das saus schwer weil du musst
irgendwie das Gefühl so du musst halt
irgendwie
mindestens 20 Rezepte auswendig wissen
weil du darfst musst ja ohne Rezepte
Kochen bücherw war so viel Stoff einfach
so gefühlt ganzes Buch für eine Prüfung
lernen also war alles andere als chillen
aber davon habe ich so viel mitgenommen
also quasi auch von diesem ganz für sich
selber kochen einfach die ganze Haushalt
und so weiter das fehlt auch den
Menschen das fehlt den Kindern das fehlt
der Jugend und den Erwachsenen heute ich
finde Hauswirtschaft ist neben Deutsch
Mathe und Englisch eigentlich so das
Hauptfach was man integrieren sollte ja
aber heute habe ich jetzt mal Ausnahme
offen weil geht dann doch irgendwie so
du dich wohlfühlst alles gut genau ist
zu groß klein machen haben Schüssel wo
das reinchen kann was ich geb dir sogar
direkt eine Pfanne D machen nich in soer
Pfanne vor allem auch hier so mit dem
Messer mit der scharfen K Brett runter
gesch ganz fataler Fehler immer mit dem
Messerrücken schabt man das
runter
herrlich so super möchtest du auch mitur
trenen Gewürzen ich glaube das Hähnchen
können wir auch mit Sojasoße hier war
noch so ein Sojasoßen Gewürz oder willst
das könen wir auch nehmen das war auch
asiatisches hähnchenengewürz soll
einfach die Gewürzmischung mit der
Gewürzmischung
mischen haben wir drauf 80 Gewürze oder
so wir werden es herausfinden ich bin
auch eher so
tendenziell extrem viel als zu wenig
gewürzt tatsächlich in der indischen
Küche sagt man man s darf die
Fleischfarbe nicht mehr
erkennen alles Senfgelb richtig ich
baller einfach alles Gewürz drauf gell
ja du ballerst einfach alles ich baller
einfach das heißt ich ma überall
eigentlich so infiles hier wie die hier
ja perfekt haben wir die gleiche Garzeit
und ich guck mal hier ich check das mal
hier kurz durch ihr geht hier
auf Beilagen und Gemüse hier ist Reis
dann Naturreis und die Info habe ich
jetzt hier raus also da steht Gefäß auf
Rost Höhe 3 eineinhalbfer Menge Wasser
Flüssigkeit Zug
dann die Dauer die stellt sich dann von
alleine ab aber es sind jetzt ungefähr
110° oder 100° Dampf 25 Minuten perfekt
das heißt wir machen den Reis rein und 5
Minuten später kommt das Hähnchen rein
und dann noch mal 5 Minuten später Fisch
und
Gemüse g auch zuletzt in der Schule
dampfgare ja gell B in Altbauwohnung
gezogen gibt's kein dampfgare da habe
ich ganz andere Sachen in der Küche
gefunden ichavon davon sollte ich glaube
ich jetzt nicht erzählen das habe ich im
Podcast erzählt oh nein was hast du da
gefunden soll ich wirklich erzählen hier
okay ja ich bin quasi jetzt vor kurz
noch umgezogen und habe jedenfalls eine
ganz tolle Wohnung gefunden aber ich bin
vom Neubau in den Altbau gezogen ich
liebe Altbau super schöne
Ziegelsteinwand hohe Decken herrlich und
meine Mom ist extra gekommen weil wir
schenken uns nicht nichts zu Weihnachten
außer halt leistungsgeschenke sie ja ich
Hälfte neuen Wohnung das ist mein
Weihnachtsgeschenk ist ja top mit die
Küche ist giftgrün die muss gestrichen
werden ich halte die Farbe nicht aus und
so weiter und was wir dann so in der
Wohnung generell so alles pöer pö
entdeckt haben hat uns ein bisschen
schockiert Punkt Nummer numero ein noch
nicht in der Küche hat sie erstmal wir
waren Hal so am wild am Putzen so war
halt sehr nicht besonders hygienisch
bist du dann auch so so Dampfreiniger
mäßig drauf oder alles mit klor bleichen
oder Hardcore scharfe Mittel aber
tatsächlich statt einem d
Hochdruck Reiniger habe ich einfach die
Wurzelbürste auf Knien Variante gewählt
oldschol kommt er sag bisschen Bad
angefangen zu putzen plözlich schreit
sopia komm mal her und ich gedacht ich
habe so ein Steinboden im Bad in so
einer dunklen Optik das war kein dunkler
Steinboden wir haben zum schrubben
angefangen und da war eigentlich so ein
hell beer Steinboden
drunter ja ich we nicht wie schafft dass
der Boden so aussehen kann es war jetzt
erstmal Überraschung Nummer ein dass man
überall wischen muss dass der Boden
alles cool und dann hö ich aber nur noch
aus der Küche ein
Würgen das bin nicht ich vertrag sowas
gar nicht und ich so m was los alles gut
komm sofort her und so und sie hat
gesehen dass bei der Küche was mit Duck
tapape ist eine ältere Küche abgeklebt
war sch sie okay so ein Loch die
Vormieterin hatte frettzchen und die
frettzchen die haben da irgendwie wie
das Loch zustande gekommen ist keine
Frage also keine Ahnung aber die sind
quasi ü das eine Loch rein und dann
haben wir das Gitter unten beim
Kühlschrank weggenommen und die haben
einfach über Jahre hinweg in diese Ecke
unterm Kühlschrank geschissen also
erstmal haben wir nur so Spielzeug
gesehen und Lappen die sie da
runtergezogen haben dann haben wir nur
was ist da in der Ecke hinten drin und
dann haben wir diese ganzen Lappen unds
ganze Spielzeug was teilweise noch
Geräusche von sich gegeben hat haben wir
rausgezogen und mir läuch TAS eckin war
die ganze Ecke voll
geschissen duchst Weg habt ihr das
geschafft ja es muss jetzt professionell
gereinigt werden voll die Messi Wohnung
dann wahrscheinlich gewesen und die
haben s wahrscheinlich nur geräumt ja
sagen ich erhle mich mal kurz vom Schock
mein Team hat jetzt hier auch schon gar
nicht zu mir
komm nür ich hab Boden Bad wenn du auf
Knien D Stunden lang dein
Badezimmerboden schrubst Workout dusus
gemacht ja so Hal me danach barolle ja
und also mein Rücken war danach Schrott
und meine Hände sowieso dann weißt du
was du gemacht hast dann lernst du diese
Wohnung aufer ganz anderen Ebene kennen
auf Balkon ging es mir auch so da ich
warte noch ich geb dir eine kurze Pause
dann kommt die nächste Story okay was
machen wir wir packen das gleich mit den
Ofen stellen das zur Seite und mein Team
hat schon ein Spiel vorbereitet ich
würde sagen jetzt geht erstmal los mit
Spiel 1 okay damit ich die Frettchen aus
dem Kopf bekomme okay sehr
g
herzlich Willkommen zu Spiel 1 es
rappelt im
Karton richtig so wie ihr seht haben wir
hinter euch fünf Kartons aufgebaut unter
diesen fünf Kartons sind fünf kuriose
Gegenstände abwechselnd werdet ihr eine
Nummer auswählen und den Gegenstand
unter dem Karton eurem Gegenüber
erklären ob ihr lügt euch einen eigenen
Gegenstand ausdenkt oder den Gegenstand
vor euch beschreibt bleibt euch
überlassen für jeden richtig erratenen
Gegenstand gibt es einen Punkt bei
falscher Antwort bekommt derjenige der
den Gegenstand beschrieben hat den Punkt
das ganze machen wir fünf Mal wir haben
fünf Kartons ihr müsst aber den Karton
natürlich nicht selbst holen wir haben
dafür einen Butler extra aus England
einfliegen lassen mit J zehnteanger
Erfahrung hier ist Mr
than und wer fängt an sopia du fängst an
okay ich hätte gern die Nummer
[Musik]
d
es wurde Türchen Nummer 3 gewählt Sally
du darfst jetzt gerne wieder deine Augen
[Musik]
aufmachen ich habe einen ganz witzigen
Gegenstand vor mir als hätte ich so auch
nicht erwartet du glaubst es kaum es ist
nämlich Serviette in origamiform in den
verschiedensten
[Musik]
tierchenversionen
das
ist das schon eingelogt jetzt bist du
dir wirklich sicher ich gehe gerade im
Kopf durch ich wäre so verrückt sein
könnte diese Dinger in
origamiform gefaltet zu haben erst
dachte ich so nee das macht sich doch
jetzt keiner diese Mühe aber doch die
sind so verrückt da liegt liegen
bestimmt servieren Origami Tierchen vor
dir ist das deine finale
Entscheidung
[Gelächter]
anderes ich muss entscheiden ja ich ich
glaube schon dass der Origami Tierchen
liegen bestimmt so ein schwar soll ich
zeigen wir haben hier ein ein Schwan oh
das ist festgeklebt ihr seid echt
verrückt ja also es sind nicht so viele
Tierchen man könnte das hier
Schmetterling interpretieren wir haben
noch andere aber es sind wirklich so
origamiiettenformen das ist
krass
schlecht okay 100 gut gemacht
ja okay okay jetzt bin ich dran ich
hätte gerne Tür Nummer 5
Paket Nummer
oh
na was hast du denn
schönes vor mir
liegt
leider weil ich bin so absolut gegen
Lebensmittelverschwendung aber ich find
es so absurd weil sie ger genau wissen
dass ich damit nicht einverstanden bin
ich muss auch richtig schimpfen mit euch
vor mir liegt
eine Tüte pomfrit von McDonald's und die
ist jetzt schon kalt die kann man jetzt
nicht mehr
essen später gibt's eine Abmahnung
ja na ja man kann ja auch theoretisch
kalte Pommes essen das ist ja keine
Lebensmittelverschwendung ja hast das
schon mal gemacht kalte
Pommes klar was Nacht vergisst Frühstück
dafür ich hatte wilde wilde Nächte vor
allem die sufnächte das sind die besten
ne da freut man sich über kalte Pizza
und kalte Pommes V wie das riecht riecht
es sogar bist du sicher mir kommt nichts
an Geruch an ja vielleicht ist deine
Nase verstopft
also es sind Pommes es sind Pommes mhm
und ich McDonald's welche Packung grröße
denkst du
Medium ist Medium glaube ich doch schon
Medium ich bin schlecht im Größen
einschätzen aber ich glaube es Medium
ich glaube das ist
gelogen sicher ich kann nicht gut lügen
nee ich glaube nicht dass vor dir Pommes
liegen ich da liegt irgendwas anderes
ist das deine Finale
Antwort
ja ja oh gott sei Dank
du bist so
gemein du nicht es das Kartoffel mit
einem Bild von uns wie lustig geil was
ist das für ein Bild wie geil du das
auch
beschrieben das ist ja krass i die Kofel
die schon weich aber das ist ja geil das
muss aufheben ich will das Bild behalten
das ist schön wir beide Boxen irer
Fantasiewelt ich find das schön oder
daraus noch Pommes machen richtig vor
allem ich habe nur gedacht warum soll es
son schwer zu beschreiben sein se so
eine Packung Pommes
we schwierig sich sowas zu überlegen ja
okay ach so was haben wir jetzt soch
übrig was guckst du Schau do nicht so
darüber ach so nee ich Dach du hast
schon nee ich nehme die zwei was guckst
du du kommst hier nicht rein nein muss
aen zuum Maen ich nehme die zwei B
please number two please thank
you was jetzt los du wirst es nicht
glauben was
was was hier auf dem Teller vor mir
liegt Sack erzähl okay und zwar eine
Hantel tatsächlich Hantel ja mit einer
riesengroßen Brille
drauf mit einem pinken Hut und noch so
kennst du diese glupschaugen quasi diese
Wackelaugen mhm aber mit Herzchen drin
also eine Hantel mit einer großen Brille
mit herzchenaugen und ein pinken Hut
welche Form hat der Hut der Hut
in Hutform halt wir haben haben hüt es
gibt eine Caps Caps sagen dann gibt's
ein Hut also kein Partyhut was ist ein
Partyhut glitzerpy geburtstagshut ist
kein spitzhütchen nein welche Größe hat
die Handel welches
Gewicht dry aber wie können das
Glubschaugen sein mit Herzchen drin so
Wackelaugen aber Hal diesem Pupillen
Herzchen du lügst ja finale
[Applaus]
Entscheidung wo kommt dieser Partyhut
her ich bin so meine ganze Requisite
durchgegangen es ist wunderschön und es
heißt 21 für mich ja jetzt geht's auch
mal los hier geil
ein
na was ist denn auf deinem
Tellerchen auf meinem
Tellerchen ist Gras was für ein
[Gelächter]
Gras m nur austrixen du willst mich nur
verwirren du kannst Verwirrung nicht
verwirren Tellerchen legten Stückchen
Gras von unserem Rollrasen draußen und
und eine kleine ein kleiner Miniatur
Rasenmäher wir hatten mal eine
Kooperation mit so einem
gartenwerkzeughersteller und der hat uns
quasi alles was wir im Garten haben auch
in Miniaturform geschickt für unsere
Barbies und deswegen habe ich so ein
Stückchen kleinen Rasen hier und so ein
kleinen Mini Rasen mehr a so aber
eigentlich enttäuscht er mich weil der
nicht rollt weißt wie ich meine die
Rollen die sind so ich zeig's dir
gleich du zeigst es mir gleich das W
vor allem ein Stück W sagt schon ein
Stück Rasen ein Stück Rollrasen weiß
nicht wie Rollrasen
verle ne Information diezugü und dann
kann quasi ja da wird so ausgelegt und W
den später wenn z. ein Stück Rollrasen
kaputt ist draußen dann kannst es
einfach wegschneiden quadratisch kauf
ich dir noch ein neues Stück Rollrasen
dazu tut mir leid aber ich glaube du
lügst sicher ja der Macht do Brum
Brum zeig
Brum ne ich habe recht oder das ist kein
Rasen ist ein Stück Rasen das
[Applaus]
stimmt aber das ein Stück Rasen ist
quasi Teil richtig Teil falsch ist ja
wirklich ein Stück Rasen aber das kein
Rasen Rasen aber ich hätte deine Taktik
übernehmen müssen und sagen müssen ich
habe ein Stück Rasen vor mir und da ist
ein ein Einhorn drauf mit ja ein
schwammeinhorn und darauf ein Sticker
mit einem Dinosaurier dann hätte ich
mich gleich enthart weil wer denkt sich
sowas schon aus ja
was oh nein ich dachte also Stück Rasen
also und dann kommt das Miniatur dann
kommt Brum Brum auch noch das hat s
abgeschossen
sorry
geil what the oh
nein was ist das willst Du reinbeißen
vielleicht
ähm okay lass mir kurz nachdenken es ist
wild
m und zwar ich habe keinen
Teller mm ich habe eine
auflaufforhm und
äh in der auflauffor ist tatsächlich
sind Spaghetti drin
gekocht ziemlich gekocht da steckt was
komisches
drin der BCK was steckt da
drin eine
Weihnachtskugel in diesem verkochten
Spaghetti die Soße kann ich dir leider
nicht
identifizieren also de
lebensmittelverschwendungsader wird
heute sehr strapaziert wie welche Farbe
hat die Weihnachtskugel grün welche
Farbe hat die auflauffor die ist
durchsichtig aus
Glas die Form die Form ist oval wie eine
Auflaufform es gibt ja verschiedene far
oval
hatfleischsoße
ich kannte die Soß nicht sagen es kann
sein dass mal Hackfleisch drin war aber
es ist einfach
rötlich alles ziemlich matchik deswegen
da what the ist gelogen gelogen in
meinem Team kocht keiner verkochte
matchike Spaghetti bist du sicher ja
vielleicht ist schief gelaufen wir Daten
komm benutzen wir fürs Spiel nein finale
[Musik]
Entscheidung ich zeig's dir
[Applaus]
sehr gut das ist sieht aus wie ein
Kameraobjektiv in grünem
gliber
Geräusche wie
eklig das ist die deine Tasse oder das
ist die
objektivtasse deine
objektivtasse ist das Götterspeise oder
ist das irgendwie kunstkliber
Götterspeise oh lecker können wir die
jetzt essen ne nein nein nein nein nein
okay
schade das war Spiel 1 dann schauen wir
mal kurz auf die Punkte sopia hat
aktuell drei Punkte
[Applaus]
und so dann prEN wir mal fleiig weiter
oder
[Musik]
ja S schwierig deine Lügen zu
identifizieren deine lügentig schwierig
ich habe gedacht ich habe kurz bei der
Spaghetti habe ich gedacht so bitte tut
es mir nicht an bitte es hat doch jetzt
keiner Spaghetti verkocht das geht doch
jetzt einfach bitte mach's einfach nicht
es war ein schweres Spiel ja auf jeden
Fall bin schon gespannt was das nächstes
kommt ja er kriegt auch langsam Hunger
weil es riecht schon langsam so nach
gürzen richtig Hunger dein Frühstück war
heute sehr ausgewogen habe ich
mitbekommen erzähl doch mal
ein Würstchen ein Würstchen aber
frühstückst du sonst nie oder nicht oder
schon regelmäßig eigentlich schon also
tatsächlich frühstücke ich meistens
sowas wie Porridge oder irgendwie
Haferflocken mit Skar ich jetzt auch am
liebsten Haferflocken irgendwie so
Porridge mäßig aber wenn W wenn ich
Besuch habe für andere gebe ich mir
richtig Mühe und will es richtig schön
machen und fancy wenn es für mich geht
dann dann wird einfach ein Haufen ne bei
dir auch ich hat ja bei mir auch also
wenn ich Reals und so Rezeptfotos mache
dann wird das pord das schönste Porridge
was ich dir gegeben hat auf der Welt
aber weißt du wo ich es extrem gemerkt
habe als ich bei Let's Dance war ja und
ich hatte ja früher früher wirklich nie
Sport gemacht wirklich gar nicht also
deswegen ich mochte dich schon immer
aber dein Content es war so ich habe dir
gerne dabei zugeguckt hab mir schon habe
mich schon gut gefühlt einfach durchs
zugucken aber ich hätte jetzt nie ein
Workout gemacht das geht mir mit
Rezepten auch so weil ich mir denke so
boah das sieht richtig geil aus abspeich
und nie nachmachen ja B du auch gern süß
oder also ich bin eigentlich nur auf süß
wenn ja ja also meine Schwäche ist
tatsächlich sowas wie so gebeck
Zimtschnecken
Hefezopf sowas ist so mein Laster oder
Mondkuchen ich liebe m oh ich auch ja
dieser mondsträzel mhm also ich ist so
es ist so keine Ahnung süß mag ich sehr
gerne und nouert ist wie Heroin für mich
also also aber auch haselnussmous in der
gesünderen Variante das esse ich jeden
Tag also das ist so mein m also das da
stinkt jedes Nutella irgendwie gegen ab
und aber salzig ma ich auch gerne und
dann auch am liebsten auch sowas wie so
ofengeschichten also grüner Spargel oder
Brokkoli einfach im Ofen mit Zwiebeln
und auch dann irgendwie Hähnchen dazu
Reis oder Kartoffeln lieber aber auch
Hardcore
Meeresfrüchte ich so gar nicht ich hatte
ein einines Erlebnis in London auf dem
borrow
market mir vlaufer Kamera einfach aus
gegeben ach aber gleich so die härteste
muss do nicht sein es war geschmacklich
okay die mag ich nicht mal obwoh ich
meres Früchte mag die Konsistenz war
brutal aus ich finde dies sind am
wenigsten schmecken die ist wie so ein
schluckhafenbecken was du einfach nimmst
das muss doch nicht sein aber so keine
Ahnung so schrims
oder Seezunge oder irgendwie sowas
gegrillter Thunfisch generell auch
Muscheln mit
Weißweinsoße heftig krank ich werde
wahrscheinlich nie wieder eine Muschel
Essen einfach nie wieder ja doch
Miesmuscheln halt oder Jakobs mususcheln
ich weiß es nicht es ist die Konsistenz
es ist ich habe es halt in der frühen
Kindheit nicht gegessen und vielleicht
ist es das das kann sein aber die
Geschmäcker verändern sich ja
bekanntlich ich habe früher auch
Koriander und Grünspargel gehasst und
heute liebe ich es aber ich kann mir
Lebensmittel auch gesund reden lecker
reden also wenn ich weiß das eine
Lebensmittel ist gesund aber ist
vielleicht nicht so mein Geschmack dann
kann ich mir das einreden dass ich es
lecker finde echt z.B Sellerie Mate ich
früher nicht mach absolut kein Sellerie
ich habe den Geruch gehasst und das war
so und ich ich liebe Sellerie ich kann
das jetzt roh das esse ich jeden Tag nö
ich habe NS gegen selie ich glaub ich
ich do nicht schön reden was kann ich
noch machen Sellerie
schneiden
ich kann nehmen ne und die rote Bee noch
oder ja genau sehr gut ich habe so ein
Verbot bekommen von der Jess wenn ich
essen mitnehme und ich bin jetzt auch
viel immer Zug gefahren weil es halt
easy ist und umweltfreundlicher als das
Auto und ich habe aber ein Verbot an
Lebensmittel die ich nicht mehr im Zug
essen darf z.B kraabi weil sie sagt es
riecht wie ein Pups nee weißt was
wirklich Pups riecht gedämpften Brokkoli
oder Blumenkohl und weiß ich hatte
einmal im Flugzeug hatte ich weil ich
früher nur Tupperware und da habe ich
mir tatsächlich gedünsteten Blumenkohl
mit Garnelen
Knoblauch
die tare war kalt das heißt da kam so
ein kalter Dampf an Furz und
Meeresgetier und knob raus ich habe es
gefeiert we geh ja wirklich aber ich
habe es einfach rigos durchgezogen weil
hallo ich war auf Diät ich hat schöne
Frau neben dir sitzen so der Traum eines
jeden Mannes denk du dir so oh mein Gott
neben dieser Frau will ich sitzen
Jackpot neben mir dann packt die diesen
Furz aus wirklich oder auch ganz
schlimme
Rosenkohl Rosenkohl mit kabelj kommt
auch ganz gut an sogar meine Eltern
haben mich verflucht ich früher den
Kabel mal im Wasserbad gemacht in der
Pfanne und dann legst du den gefrorenen
Kabel ja auch rein und dann kommt so ein
richtiger Dampf der dur ganze Haus zieht
und meine Mama wenn du die Tür nicht
mehr zust Kü wenn dies scheiß Kabel
machst dann schmeiß ich dich raus ganze
BU einfch Fischkutter gerochen und dazu
noch ein bisschen Rosenkohl also
generell hab mE auch schon so es gibt
halt so so Fisch hält sich auch nicht
lange und ich hatte dir doch wie du
vorhin erzählt hast schubladentasche
hattest du so gemeint hat dabei und wenn
da die Kühlkette unterbrochen ist dann
wird's auch spannend wenn Sommer ist und
so ein bisschen die Sonne drauf scheint
auf dein Fischgericht dann wird's auch
sehr spannend aber ich habe es trotzdem
gegessen ich hatte ja nichts
anderes aber hattest du mal so eine
richtig Lebensmittel Vergiftung oder
irgendwas ähnliches nee ich hab ein
Saumagen also ich bin bei allem ziemlich
irgendwie robust also ich bin wie so
Müllschlucker du kannst irgendwas was
schon pelzig ist und so kurz bevor es
davon läuft kann fressen passiert gar
nichts also ich bin glaub ich das
Gegenteil was man kuchenbe
nenn wenn Du zu mir kommst du weißt was
es gibt in meiner frchencheiß
Küche ich komme nicht mal besuchen in
deiner frchen Küche bis dahin soll
wirklich weg sein und sauber so bring
mein Dampfreiniger mit sehr gut finde
ich gut diese erdigen Dinger schneide
ich weg diese
da ich habe dich schon mal
mitgefressen warum Stä ich eigentlich
den
kraab ich mag das holzige vom sparel
übrigens also Kön du bestimmt auch
komische einerungsbans also
Essens also wooll wir anfangen also ich
mag tatsächlich das holzige vom Spargel
m ich mag Milchhaut kennst du wenn sich
auf der Milchhaut bildet streiten uns
immer drum in der Familie ja das mag ich
gerne da ganz viele ganz schrecklich
aber ich kann keine Wurstzipfel Essen
z.B oh voll
geil ja doch ich mag auch Klumpen in
Proteinshake nee ich mag nur Klumpen in
KA auch
lich ja erst das jemand kennt der der
Klumpen
mag ne ichem kenn der W Zipfel
ma generell die die Scherze die Enten
von irgendwas auch vom Brot und so sind
schon gut ich liebe nutellaabrot mit
Salami ach nö doch also da zieh ich eine
Grenze also also was ich liebe
nutellaabot mit scharfskäse das verstehe
ich oder mit einer Scheibe
Emmentaler drauf aber es muss em sein
kein gauter weil es müssen Löcher drin
sein damit das Nutella von unten so ach
muss optisch da durchqu
aber bei Käse verstehe ich auch Käse
kann man oft süß essen okay kühneffe
brutal ja brutal ja das war ich bin
eigentlich gar nicht so
komisch cool haben schon alles Avocado
noch die Avocado ja die können wir dann
am Ende so auf aber die sehr wür sagen
jetzt packen wir auch gemüsefleisch
beide Steinhart Fisch in Ofen hier ist
alles ready und wir gehen über zu Spiel
Nummer 2
kommen wir zu Spiel 2 parkcours auf Zeit
wir haben jetzt fünf Minispiele die ihr
nacheinander absolvieren müsst als
erstes spielen wir Babyrassel wie ihr
neben euch sehen könnt stehen dort
Flaschen mit Murmeln drin ziel des
Spiels ist es die Murmeln auf die andere
Seite zu schütteln da ist das Spiel aber
noch nicht vorbei wer das geschafft hat
dreht die Flasche um und versucht erneut
die Murmeln auf die andere Seite zu
befördern wer zuerst die Babyrassel
durchgeschüttelt hat drückt im bzer und
gewinnt somit die Runde ich gebe euch
das Zeichen 3 2 1
Los
h
sch hallo
[Applaus]
ja jetzt spielen wir von der Rolle ihr
könnt euch schon denken um was es geht
ihr müsst beide kpbänder auf die Arme
Rollen B du den Boden verlassen bis die
Rolle am Boden weg ist und dann auf den
bzer drücken wer zuerst den buzer drückt
gewinnt den Punkt okay 3 2
ein
wo sind die
Rollen den Boden verlassen
nice mehr gesehen Wste gar nicht
was die Gesichter wahrscheinlich in
SL Minispiel Nummer 3 heißt du hast da
was im
Gesicht
ihr werdet gleich einen Keks auf die
Stirn platziert bekommen und ihr müsst
ihn ohne Hände in den Mund befördern
falls er runterfällt muss er natürlich
wieder auf die Stirn platziert werden du
musst die von der Stirne in den Mund
kriegen ja ohne mit der Hand den Keks zu
berühren soweit verstanden es geht los
in 3 2
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
1 Stück für
Stück das rutscht einfach gar nicht me
der Stirn
oh
ah ich habe mit Stirnrunzeln Versuch ja
ich auch ich arbeite mich
vor zu
weit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ne
Scheiße nein ich bin schon mus ich
selber oder ich bin schon am
Auge nur zugreifen men oh
au oh was ist wenn das mit einfach mit
Hauruck probiert wie so ein Hund W man
einfach so wegschnappt denkst
du okay ich GL ich glaub
[Musik]
nicht ich bin hoch
konzentriert okay
Moment
[Gelächter]
ich muss auch auf die
Schulter ich will auch ins
Auge auf
[Gelächter]
Auge si wie OL Scholz
mit
rot so eine richtig so eine
schaufelzunge wä jetzt gut g kann man
einach fallen
lassen ich habe ihn aber
[Musik]
angelckt das schast du
niemal ich will auch auf die Schulter
kriegen irgendwie ich dachte kann jetzt
von meiner Brust zählt das das zählt ja
oh wie H
[Applaus]
wie
dr geil dem Gesicht und mit meiner
Schulter gefangen Runde Nummer 4 heißt
Farbenspiel vor euch stehen Schokolinsen
die ihr nur mit einer Hand nach Farben
sortieren müsst wer sie als erstes
sortiert hat drückt den buzer und
gewinnt den Punkt seid ihr bereit ja 3 2
oh die Klingen unterschiedlich die
[Musik]
Farben was machst du was schüttelst du
darum ich habe ausesehen falsche
Glas wie jetzt aber sind do keine noch
irgendwelche Gläser für irgendwelche
Farben ne ich hatte dann zwei Gläser mit
grün oder blau oder
okay
ja was
geht du hast bestimmt irgendwas mit
Knöpfen früh ja tatsächlich ich musste
immer die Knöpfe meiner oder was heißt
die musste meine Mama die näht und er
hat immer Stoff und Knöpfe und alles und
ich habe immer alle Knöpfe bei ihr nach
Farben sortiert ja da kommt hier und da
hier was hier da kommen die Stories raus
aber das das erinnere mich jetzt nur
dran weil du das gesagt hast ja das H
hab mich voll daran erinnert dass so wie
wild Knöpfe sortier die hatte auch immer
diese Keksdose diese Butterkekse ja
undch die auf so 100000 Knöpfe drin es
ist aber knapp auch mit den Punkten
glaube ich es liegt daran weil ich
Hunger habe ich will en okay kommt wir
machen
weiter als letztes Minispiel spielt ihr
bis zum Umfallen wichtig zu wissen sopia
du führst mit fünf Punkten und Sally du
liegst knapp dahinter mit vier Punkten
also wäre es jetzt wichtig sopia
entweder dein Vorsprung zu erweitern
oder das S auf Gleichstand zieht ihr hab
beide einen Luftballon in der Hand den
ihr aufpusten werdet und ihr müsst mit
den Ballon diese ganzen Becher die vor
euch stehen umwerfen wer als erstes alle
Becher zum Umfallen bringt drückt den
bzer und gewinnt den
Punkten gen erst abpusten okay Moment
okay 3 2
ja
[Gelächter]
ohuste knapp okay jetzt habe ich Hunger
wir müss essen wir essen jetzt was
[Musik]
oh das war lustig das war se lustig die
Spannung war wirklich auf dem
Peak perfekt ja gut unser Essen ist
jetzt auch fertig und falls ihr das zu
Hause auch so zuereiten wollt ihr könnt
ihr jetzt praktisch alles auch Abfüllen
in eure Vorratsbehälter in Kühlschrank
packen und jeden Tag macht man sich so
eine Bowl wie man sie gerne mag man kann
sie erwärmen man kann sie kalt essen ich
bin da auch so ein Mensch ich muss nicht
alles warm haben manchmal esse ich es
gern kalt wie so ein Salat und jeder
stellt sich das zusammen wie er möchte
haben noch so drei socen vorbereitet und
ja oder ja bef mal wie wir es brauchen
soll ich auch ein bisschen Reis gerne
[Musik]
das S unsere fertigen bows W sagen wir
essen schon mal ja so hunger so
lecker umräumen fürs letzte Spiel und
dann schauen wir mal wer hier heute das
Rennen macht kannst überhaupt noch
gewinnen ich
wei ein
Spiel mal
gucken
wie man sich schon denken kann spielen
wir jetzt Multiple Choice ihr habt vor
euch Karten mit A B C und D legen wenn
ihr denkt die Antwort zu wissen hängt
ihr vorne an eurem Magnet die Antwort so
dass die Kamera es sieht und dann lösen
wir im Nachhinein auf genau so nach
vorne was ist das Frage 1 welche
sportartenkombination gibt es wirklich a
Schnickschnack schnuckballett B huler
Hub reiten C schachboxen oder D
wasserschiennis
was ist richtig wir lösen auf C ist die
richtige
Antwort was passiert da bei
schachboxen
schachm Frage 2 unter was wird ein
Fußballprofi beim Arbeitsamt geführt
wenn er seinen Job verliert a als
Sportler B als Künstler C als Fußballer
oder d
das ist irgend so eine tricky
[Musik]
Frage was Sportler und Athlet echt ich
muss es leider raten beide haben
eingeloggt die richtige Antwort wäre B
gewesen keiner lag
richtig gedacht Künstler aber warum weil
s Schauspielern wenn sie auf wenn sie
hinfallen so
Frage 3 was bedeutet Karate wörtlich
übersetzt a umschmeißen B Ohrfeige C
Kaffeepause oder D leere Hand Karate
ohfeige was
zweite
feige ich g wegen der Höflichkeit und
die richtige Antwort ist d ja ja du auch
ich auch ja ja weil ich dachte so es ist
nicht so asiatisch so Ohrfeige und
umrempeln wenn dann W so leere Hand ist
so dachte ich auch W Kaffeepause macht
keinen Sinn und das erste wäre sumoring
eigentlich oder umwerfen und so aus dem
Ring super dann kommen wir jetzt zur
Siegerehrung wie sieht der Punktestand
aus z war ein knappes Rennen sally hat
insgesamt sechs Punkte
erspielt
und Sophia hat knapp mit einem Punkt
mehr nämlich sieben Punkten das Rennen
für sich entscheiden
können aber richtig cool
[Musik]
mega diesen s Weltpokal oh mein Gott
verdient
gewonnen ich habe ein Pokal ich geb
sonst nie was ganz lieben Dank dass du
bei mir zu Gast warst danke schön noch
mal richtig schön mit dir hmäig richtig
cool es war der Wahnsinn ich hoffe ihr
hattet auch viel Spaß dabei ihr könnt
gerne mal schreiben wer noch zu Gast in
die Küche kommen soll und wir werden uns
wiedersehen und wieder Rezepte machen
wir haben einige Shorts und reels auch
gedreht findet ihr auf dem Kanal war
noch weihnachtscontent tatsächlich aber
wir werden uns auch jetzt im neuen Jahr
natürlich Wiedersehen ja auf jeden Fall
nicht erst wieder in SE Jahren nein
bitte nicht also macht's gut bis zum
nächsten Mal
tschüss ich glaube ich werde in meiner
Sendung einfach nie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gewinnen